but in terms of talking to everybody
your supporters and your opponents and
those in the middle I don't think
Twitter can be beat uh he has 87 million
followers on Twitter he has a little
over three million uh followers I think
on true social it could be a little off
on that uh let's say that a substantial
number of the people following me on
Twitter are Bots
let's say it's 50 which I don't think it
is yeah well that means he has 42
million people I mean that's still an
enormous number so I'm hopeful that he
will begin posting this this uh content
this video content particularly he
doesn't have to use Twitter you know for
his for his sniping yeah which he loves
to do of course uh which is just kind of
part of his political persona but I do
think he needs to occasionally
occasionally go back on Twitter
[Music]
[Applause]